WELCOME ALL NEW SUBSCRIBERS!
After the Logan Paul hate rants,
We're gonna. Don't worry. I'm not gonna disappoint!
What you've subscribed for, you're gonna get. Okay?
So let's talk about some anime.
That's why you subscribed.  Ani *clap* me *clap*  reviews, thank you yes
This is what everyone wants from this channel. You're welcome everybody.
Devilman Crybaby came out on Netflix
Last weekend. I was pretty gripped by it. I thought the art
Style was so cool that, I was, I had to check it out right away. this sort of
Glimpse of hope lit up inside me
*:o* huh? is it possible?
Netflix actually made something decent in terms of anime no. *NO!*
Felix have you already forgotten about blam your favorite manga
*slap* BWAH
What about Death Note, one of your favorite anime they butchered it
Don't let this abuse continue
so I looked up about Devil man cry-baby
If there was reviews about it just so my hope wouldn't be
Destroyed completely, and I couldn't find any I guess it was just it just came out or something like that
but it made me look up where the original came from and, eh,
I looked up the original manga and it's made by a gent called Go Nagai.  now allegedly
I don't know for sure but people were saying that he inspired
Can't, with devil man,
Kentaro Miura, which is the creator of berserk one of the greatest manga of all time(?) It's not but you know, it´s pretty good. (giggling)
He did talk of Miyazaki who created Dark Souls and blood-borne and
Gochi Suda (it used tobe goat cheese sunnah lmao), which is of course creator of legendary game studio?
Suit at 51. I thought that was pretty awesome, and I was like oh
I can't believe I never heard of devil man. It seemed like a really a big
Imprint in Japanese animation nerd culture, so I decided to read the manga
first
and eh...
It's okay?
It's, it's okay. basically the devil man
Crybaby, story is you have Akira who is this very typical. He's kind of a loser. He's a crybaby
he doesn't know how to fight
and
He then gets to become
half demon
half human
Or a demon with a human heart and he becomes devil man to fight other demons it sounds extremely basic
It sounds like the plot of spider-man. once you keep reading
You realize it's not it goes from very cute to very quickly very dark and very adult now apparently the manga was
originally a concept for a
child-friendly TV show.
*Devil man 90's theme playing in background*
And also was made into an anime which has the best
English dub of all time just just just watch this
HHIIIYAH!
Stop it! stop it! don't break my shell!!
If you do you won't just kill me, you'll kill all these people as well!
Think I give a fuck.. Think again!!!!!
Think I give a fuck think AGaInNN
What I did like about the manga was that it had an ending unlike a lot of Shonen
Manga. Naruto, one piece, they just go on forever and there once you get a hit
You know you just keep going and going. It's a story it tells it and that's it. It doesn't try to do anything else although
It's been
apparently at that
Readapted just a couple times. Just a couple times. We have Devilman anime, mazinger z vs devilman
shin devil man, true devil man, devil man the demon bird!
devil man lady ;) (snorting)
Doshi devil man. devil man lady again!
Neeeo Devil man.
Amon, The Dark Side of the devil man.
Amon: the apocalypse of the devil man
New Demon Lord Danteh (wot)
Devilman Strange days, Demon Knight, KRINKWOL (wot???)
And thats not even all of them. Its really, shouldn't be a surprise
Looking at all this that Netflix bought to do their own remake of this for their platform.
But I think the big surprise here is that??
*Beckons closer*
free real estate n my backyard boy
*beckons closer again*
It's good it's really good. I think why I really like devil man Cry-baby is because it's...
Its source material at least sets off to be a typical
superhero.. um,
kind of story
It's it's really not and it uses that
Against you to kind of throw you off and do things that you wouldn't normally expect it.
I think with this
Readaptation of the anime they really took a lot of risk to do some really crazy stuff, and it really paid off
Starting off with the art style. It's. very
aesthetic. AESTHETIC!
i Love the art style and it's what drew me in first some of my favorite animes are
Literally just purely based of the artstyle and the art direction. It's got this very clean
Not your typical anime style it reminded me a little bit of Kaiba the anime mainly in the colors the kind of yellowish
tones even fooly cooly
Don't hurt me for saying that it reminded me of a little bit the animation really works
It's very silly at a lot of times
It's silly when it needs to be or wants to be but it's also serious when he wants to be which is
It's a nice contrast if you thought the
The running style in Naruto looked silly then you haven't seen the running style
in devil man, it's a
It's 10 out of 10 it's the best I run like this all the time whenever I'm late
That's how I decide to run for extra speed and momentum
So you have this really amazing really interesting art style, but then
There's more you get the soundtrack which is so damn good you got pieces with Simanese
type of ah an
Homage to the 70s which is when the manga came out, and it really works everything just works
*Sick dubstep Devil man music*
But it also has some chillingly good emotional pieces or one after another there's so many great tracks on this
And I'm definitely gonna buy the soundtrack when it comes out. I really loved it
There's this one song that plays at a certain time (song playing)
I mean, I'm not gonna spoil it
but it was definitely my favourite part of the whole anime. Marzia was sitting next to me when I was watching it and
She wasn't really watching, but she noticed that -  I remember she's saying like oh, that's a really nice song
That's playing and I was just like yes
Yes it is. no spoilers, but since I read the manga. There's a character definitely in the story
I read the manga so I knew he was coming
But the way they dealt with this a hundred times better than I could ever ask for it was it was a truly beautiful
Moment that really caught me off guard and that made me just stop
Just to really think wow this anime is really incredible you, you got - you. Got incredible art style you got
Incredible soundtrack and you got a great story and all these three things
really tying together so nicely and
That's why I really really loved it, and that's why I really love anime and I have all these different
elements of art coming together, and it's
It's very nice. It's a very nice, and they really pulled it off here in devil man
cry-baby. in the anime they tried to
Give some characters a bit more depth they uh, they added the whole story about
Running the characters past the pole to each other. I don't know what that sport is called in English but
They added that to give the character more depth and it worked.. to a certain extent.
I I think that the characters are a bit shallow in the manga
And they unfortunately still are in the anime I didn't really care too much about a lot of them, and they could probably
Wasn't that important. now,
What really annoyed me the most
And probably the biggest flaw in the anime and why - I think I read polygon calling it a masterpiece
I'll tell you why it's not a masterpiece because the last episode really falls flat.
I would almost recommend that you don't even watch the last episode of the anime and
Read the manga. it has a plot twist, and it's a really good plot twist
But in the anime they sort of just went.. tada
But didn't expect this huh?huuh?heh?
Well in the manga. It's it's more of
understanding it yourself sort of
putting the pieces together and then having this realization oh (Sh*t)
This is what happened and that's really cool. You think this is just eh e-
your typical
shonen superhero anime or manga
but it's really not and he uses that against you to deliver this plot twist which I thought was really cool and really clever and
It it also also the manga really brings up some
Interesting themes about what it means to be human
What it means to be good or evil if the if the manga poked these things with a stick the anime just sort of like
Glances over it like okay. We're not gonna go near that but overall
Good job Netflix. You finally did it you've made something good and that deserves a round of applause. I'm gonna give devil man cry-baby
a solid...
I want to give it an 8, but it 7.8  it's a 7.8 strong art style
I'm gonna give a 9 soundtrack. I'm gonna give it a 9. I didn't like the intro and the outro that much and
the art style
unfortunately seem like they did lose a little a bit of
Budget because a lot of a lot of backgrounds are just black a lot of backgrounds are replaced with this ugly
Textures. it looks terrible, so I can't give it a 10 even though I want to and then the story.....
You tried it was all right. What did you think about devil man...., baby? Let me know in the comments
I really I really I'm just happy
I think the reason why I really really like it is because it had that one moment that I talked about and that
Just sort of redeemed every quality every bad thing for the anime if- to be honest
I think that's how I look at a lot of times on anime
There's this one bit that really struck a chord with you that really resonated with you or left an emotional impact
That's how I pick my favorite animes if they have that one moment where I go "Holy shit that really -
That was amazing" and the devil man, crybaby had that for me
so I'm very grateful for that and I'm very grateful for everyone working on it, and I'm talking too long so goodbye and
Remember to leave a like we're almost at 60 million
Subscribers subscribe for more anime reviews everybody, and I'll see you next Wednesday for another
Logan Paul video every Wednesday now
squad fam out
(anime) "Bakiro-kun!"
*recorder version of sonic the hedgehog starts playing*